this is chess openings explained I'm
Jonathan Thompson today we're going to
take another viewer submission from
YouTube I mean this time Colt greven
this is your suggestion you wanted to
see the Queens gambit declined and he
wanted a very specific variation which
is nice I like to go really deep into
one particular variation so don't feel
afraid to say you know I want to see
this variation these exact moves and so
he gave me 11 moves and that's what
we're going to go over today but before
we we look at where the pieces are going
to go in this opening it's important to
always look at the pawn structure so
we're going to jump over to the board
now and we're going to take a look at a
very famous pawn structure that we'll
see in this variation does anyone know
the name of this pawn structure you must
yeah the Carlsbad pawn structure it can
come from a variety of different
openings so today it's going to come
from the Queens gambit declined which is
probably the variation that it comes
from the most it can also come from an
Enzo the caro-kann it happens a lot
even that Grune felled it occasionally
happens so it's one of those things
where understanding the pawn structure
is going to help you understand why
people are putting their pieces where
they are and how they're coming up with
middle game plans and this is a nice one
to look at because there's already an
imbalance we'll notice that white has a
two pawns minority over here on the
Queen side and on the Kings side he has
this majority with all these pawns here
and what's kind of nice for white is
initially when we see it okay we might
notice he has two pawns in the center
compared to blacks one which is kind of
a nice feature also we'll see which way
the pawns are pointing this is going to
help us determine where we should be
playing where we should be putting our
pieces so we'll notice that the white
pawns are pointing towards the Queen
side and the black pawns are pointing
towards the Kings side so we're going to
know typically white is going to want to
play on the Queen side he's going to use
a minority attack he's going to try to
get some positional accomplishments over
there that will take a look at justice
second and black is going to play for a
King side attack and use all of his
pieces to try to make the King so now
the typical plan for white is to play b4
and b5 this will let us if we can manage
to take on c6 and we'll just we'll go
ahead and put that on the board bulla
obviously we're going to assume that
there's there's more pieces on the board
so whenever white gets to play this he
gets to play the move b5 Black has three
options he can take I don't know why
it's not let me do it but he could take
he can push or he can ignore and let
white take on c6 so if he takes for
example we'll assume this pawn is going
to get eaten up either by you know a
bishop or there's sometimes a rook on b1
so imagine that pawn gets eaten and now
we'll notice a white wants a lot of play
on the Queen side and now the C file is
completely open so that's something a +
and you'll have a lot of pressure on the
B file so that's to his advantage and
you'll notice the d5 pawn is now
isolated so that can become a target
sometimes so black usually is not going
to want to take he's probably not really
going to want to push because most of
the time you whenever you push will
assume this pawn gets eaten up because
you know they'll be pieces on the board
and then black will be left with an
isolated d5 pawn which you can sometimes
do it is an idea for black but again
it's a small positional achievement for
white and if you're allowed just to take
on c6 then you'll get a position like
this where now there's a weak pawn on a
half-open file so you can assume like
rooks are going to go there and you're
going to get this night out nice outpost
for a knight so you can imagine the
knight jumping in to the c5 square and I
if you really want to see domination of
c5 Danny might know this game you can
look up Rubinstein verse George Saul way
from the 1908 Lodz tournament so I hope
you know that game right good because
yeah so that's a great game and it's in
the same pawn structure so that was at
rush defense but again it's the same
family upon structures okay and it's
easy for white to come up with all sorts
of different breaks in this position so
we know about the b5 break Oh
so sometimes we might see them play
efore usually he prepares it with f3 and
that's the plan that uh that all greven
wants to see tonight so that's what
we're going to be be focused on and the
point is if you you know black has to
take at some point you know she will get
these hanging pawns but if sometimes
it's in a position we'll see today
whenever you get to play e5 in you get
this square like for a knight you get
some some really good active play so
that's what we're going to think about
it you'll notice it's kind of hard for
black to think about any breaks that he
might possibly have here because again
if ever he plays c5 and we'll take and
then this guy will be eaten up but he'll
be left with this this weakness here on
d5 so that usually doesn't happen so why
would anybody want to play this with
black well black is going to get a lot
of active piece play he's going to put a
rook that's controlling the e4 square at
some point the knight that usually goes
to f6 is going to jump in there that's
going to be an awesome night and he's
going to play for a King side attack if
you can imagine the King on g1 and you
know he has a lot of pieces name that
way he's got his Bishop and his queen
and you know the rook will come over and
sometimes it'll come over and try to
checkmate the King so this is what black
is playing for he's going for an all-out
attack and okay we'll put some pieces on
the board so we can see what's really
going on but we'll keep those two plans
in mind for white there's the b5 pawn
break and the f3 and e4 break and for
black we're going to look at some some
active piece play so let's get some
pieces on the board okay so I'm going to
we're going to get to the theory here a
little bit and this is the preferred
move order by our submitter from YouTube
so all right so it's d4 d5 c4 the
queen's gambit and today we're going to
look at the Queens gambit declined so
his a preferred move order here is
Knight c3 so we're going to definitely
check that out
you'll notice the plan that white wants
to set up when he wants to play the
lines with F 3 and E 4 it's usually
going to involve this Knight not heading
to the natural square but to e 2 so you
might wonder if you want to play the
exchange variation why not just take
right
way well if we do something like this
it'll likely transpose to what we're
going to look at tonight but black also
has a really cunning move if he knows
that his opponent wants to put his
Bishop on g5 you can play the move c6
and now wait is kind of stuck he needs
to come up with you know some reasonable
move and it's almost to the point where
okay really I just got to think about
making some natural move so I can play
e3 and get my Bishop out so some most
people will prefer to bring the knight
out first and now Knight f6 just the
most logical move and we're going to
look at the exchange variation usually
when somebody says we're going to look
at exchange variation you think of
something very boring and tedious
usually it's not a whole fun lot of fun
to look at but the nature of this
exchange is imbalance the pawn structure
is a little bit different for both sides
and in general it just scores the best
for white so this exchange variation is
actually one of the best ways that white
can try to play for an advantage in this
position now you might wonder what
happens if we take with the knight and
there's a famous game between polka FC
and tall from a us SR championship in
1969 where this was played and it's
thought to be inferior we'll just breeze
through this one game so you can get an
idea in case this happens to you over
the board white will get a really big
Center and now it's looking a lot like a
grünfeld
except now after some moves he gets to
put his knight on f3 without ever having
to worry about any Bishop to g4 which is
you know slightly improved version for
white which is why black tend to you
know typically won't play this but if
you're a Greenfeld player then go ahead
so when Boyd has such a big Center black
needs to liquidate he's got to get some
of the pieces off the board so the
center doesn't crush him so in this game
that was played and again we're just
going to breeze through it just so you
can see what's going on here okay and in
this position why it's going to get
ready he's going to play d5 so after
some moves he prepares that he brings
both of his rooks into the game and now
the most common move is actually ripped
to c8 after which white plays d5 but in
this game we saw a different plan and
now a very nice pawn sacrifice so he
broke open the center
and we'll see in just a second why I'm
showing you this game so if you know
anything about me you'll know why I'm
showing you this position so Danny knows
I can tell by his face what would white
play in this position right so a great
gift yes so have you seen some of my
previous lectures you know how much I
love the Greek gift so here's another
example yes so the bishop takes and now
the knight jumps in and again if if you
want to watch that lecture that's a
lecture for another time but there's the
four squares black and choose from this
is the only one that gives them any
chance of saving it today that's not
really why we're we're looking at this
today but okay then a white managed to
have a really nice attack here so this
is just a real brief example but okay so
we're not really going to focus on this
line today so we'll go back and we'll
we'll assume that they take with a pawn
you just should know that taking with
the knight is also an option so it does
it does occur a lot and I guess the only
reason I'm really putting the the knight
takes into the lecture is because I was
playing Mario Roper in a blitz game and
he took with his knight so people do it
so I thought I'd just share that with
you guys real quick but now we'll get
we'll get focused again and see takes d5
e takes d5 and now we're waiting with
our knight Knight f3 is a totally fine
move but we're waiting because we might
want to put the night on e to which
we'll see in just a moment so we bring
our Bishop out and now this is a there's
one of two moves there's this and
there's also Bishop e7 or even he
mentioned that you know okay they might
be able to play this line and it's such
a natural move so I thought I'd show you
just one possible tactical continuation
just because it's really cool here if
they play this line and then we'll go
back and we'll look at the move c6 in
this position okay so after some normal
developing moves we're going to notice
where we're going to put our night on e
- the reason is we're going to play F 3
and E 4 and break in the center so after
a few normal moves if black continues
without playing the move c6 will notice
that there's a really cool tactical move
and that's b4 so
the first question is what happens if
this Bishop takes the pawn what's going
on here who is the the master tactician
in the room yeah so Danny sees it right
Bishop takes f6 if you take with the
Queen then you're dropping this pawn
here which is going to be good for white
and so okay if they take this way to
keep their pawn protected there's even
more coming so what else what are we
going to do in this position
awesome so Danny's on fire tonight
Knight takes d5 right so what's going on
here what is what have we fallen into if
we give it up a piece all right and then
the last move that you would need to see
yeah awesome all right Queen a for a
double attacks you get your piece back
you ruined black's pawn structure and
you won upon so a nice tactical way and
these sorts of things happen not just in
this position but often White is trying
to play B for tactically based on the
fact that there'll be some tricks when
the other Bishop moves away and you'll
notice if there was a pawn on c6 there'd
never be this Queen a for attacking a
rook business so okay so c6 is just a
nice move for black to play alright and
now he likes to play the move order
Queen to c2 which is a very good move
order the point is you're preventing the
bishop from going to f5 so black really
wants this bishop to come out here so we
can imagine if instead we play e3 now
black can go ahead and put this bishop
here and this is another line that
usually can prevent it with Queen c2 or
you can allow it if you like this
variation the Queen will come out to f3
and when the bishop moves back we'll be
able to double the pawns but black has a
lot of compensation here it's it's kind
of an interesting position to play if
you want to take a look at it black has
the two bishops he has the G file in
this Knight is probably going to make an
appearance
on d6 so we can imagine a typical route
that it might take
and it's a really long route but once it
gets to d6 it's looking in at a lot of
these light squares so it'll be a really
powerful piece and the close nature of
the position means that he might get to
make all of these these moves so that's
an interesting position Nigel short is a
the most current player that he really
likes to play that position so he'll
play that all the time as black but
Queen c2 just prevents that whole
variation so all right Bishop to e7 okay
now we're just getting ready we're going
to put our bishop on d3 and then we can
put our night on e too so this is
probably the most accurate you can also
Castle and okay we play some a few
normal moves and here he asks what to do
if our opponent plays a move like Knight
age five so you can you know he's going
to make you trade the dark squared
bishop so we'll look at that last we'll
save that for last and Danny will like
that game because his two favorite moves
are played f2 and King f2 so stay tuned
if I show you first you might not stick
around I got to keep you here all right
so okay so we'll get to the the line
here that he wants to see 92 now
typically as we mentioned before when we
were looking at the pawn structure he's
getting ready at some point he's going
to plant a knight on e4 so he needs to
get his rook out of the way
and there's another maneuver that we can
check out the knight often goes to f8
and so this is an important maneuver to
understand for both sides
his plan is kind of sneaky he doesn't
like this Queen and Bishop that are on
this very nice strong diagonal and he
has a way to try to get them out of
there in that way is to maneuver a
knight to the g7 square and then you can
play Bishop to f5 so this is a kind of a
slow plan but with the closed position
you can get away with this sort of thing
and he tries to take away one of White's
really aggressively placed pieces so
that's a one thing we're going to keep
our eye on and okay so today he wants to
see the move f3 and so this is what
we're going to look at so now we're
going to jump into a real game here
okay so this is a famous game between
Mikhail Botvinnik and Paul Kira's it was
played in 1952 in Moscow so okay and
we'll see it I believe it was a slightly
different move order at the beginning so
we'll notice now if black wants you can
go into an Enzo Indian but instead after
d5 we're back to the position the way
that we understand so we trade we're
playing in the exchange today and we
bring our Bishop out okay now he allowed
D variations you know he didn't play
Queen c2 right away so he allowed some
variations but okay black wasn't into it
we'll get back to our main position here
and we'll understand what's going on
okay so yeah f3 was the move here then
we're going to play in this game he
began with rook b1 which is often a
common theme but he's going to change
his mind in a second once black starts
to play inaccurately and he's going to
go for the f3 e for plan so right so
this is a typical plan Y intends like b4
b5 and then taking here and creating a
weakness on the Queen side meanwhile
blacks going to go for an attack if his
attack fails then white will win in the
long run so it is often a matter of
style you like to play aggressive chess
or do you like to defend against the
attack and then you know you're going to
win in the long run so a real clash of
styles and okay his opponent though
played a really strange move he moved
the same piece twice and it's it's not a
very good one especially if you know the
plan now sometimes you know F 3 and E 4
is going to come with the additional
threat of 'if I've forking these two
pieces so it's not a very good square
for the bishop other than that the only
reason you would put it there is because
you have one cheapo so he's hoping he
gets away with it
if white continues with just before
what's blacks a little trick right
Bishop takes h2 check the point is you
gave up your bishop but you're going to
win this guy in a second Knight to g4
check and wherever the King goes you
take the bishop and then on a good day
you go and you give checkmate so that's
his trick now Botvinnik is
obviously going to see this so he came
up with a really good move here
hopefully that didn't give it away but
uh how should he protect his pawn he did
it in a really clever way he simply
moved his King over to h1 so now Bishop
takes h2 isn't with check if you do the
same thing hoping that I take it and
then you get to get the same position
all instead insert the solutions up
first and then when you take back I'll
win a piece so alright so very clever
move he just moves his King to the side
and h1 is a nice square for the King
once you start moving your F pawn so
you'll be happy all right and that's why
after Knight to g6 bringing more Knights
into the picture typically white black
wants to play a move like h6 to kick
this bishop away and okay this Knights
preventing the bishop from running away
but it won't work in this position so
white didn't go for b4 he instead one
for you know play in the center knowing
that okay we're coming now with a big
threat because if we get e5 on the board
we're gonna we're gonna pin some pieces
or fork some pieces okay so yeah he felt
compelled to put his Bishop back you
might want to play a move like h6 this
was probably kind of his intention but
now there's some problems because
sometimes you're going to lose a pond
there's going to be some some tricks
here okay let's see so and also so we
can think about just taking if we just
take which is probably fine and then we
push efore and we're coming with this
really big threat here that looks pretty
bad for black even if you try to go
somewhere where you're still protecting
your knight but you're getting out of
one fork if you play here for example
you're gonna start running into another
now these pawns are coming fast and
white just keeps coming with too many
threats so this would be a disaster for
black you'd also have to contend with a
sacrifice like this the point is we're
getting at your King so you see we're
going to sacrifice piece we're going to
get at least three ponds and okay this
is probably not the best way for white
to play but if something black would
have to consider
you know he'll bring his bishop back and
he'll defend a little bit but it's you
know a strong initiative for white here
comes the night and you know the night's
going to come harass you so this is
another sacrifice he has to be on the
watch for so he felt like he had to just
put his Bishop back on e7 admitting that
he made a mistake okay so he could now
play e4 that's an okay move here but he
does something really nice which
grandmasters like to do he prepared it
for a long time he made sure all of his
pieces were ready and then whenever he
feels like it he'll play e4 so he's not
going to play b4 so he brings another
rook to the center now these rooks are
really well placed and it's okay he's
saying black you don't really have a
good plan any typical checkmating attack
patterns that you might have they're not
going to work now because you're not
getting your knight here so okay
again h6 has like some some typical
problems you know it's it's used for to
try though there are some tricks the
point is if you just go try to win this
pawn this pawn is hanging so there are
some some tricks here you know you might
want to take and then you know protect
your pawn so h6 actually is possible to
play here but he instead moves his
knight back so he can trade the
dark-squared bishop and then he can
start to get after the e pawn and now
which typically happens in these
variations whenever there's a capture on
e7 is black has the option of which way
he wants to capture and they're both
actually quite normal often they
actually take with the rook you might be
thinking you would take with with the
Queen get some more pressure on e3 but
very often you know blacks going to hope
he's going to double maybe the Queen is
actually going to be better on c7 so in
this position he took with his his rook
also the Queen might scoot over put more
pressure okay so he took with this rook
now there is a threat on this pawn so he
gets his knight out of the way now his
Knight is also supporting the e4 square
the only thing there might be a little
tender if he plays this move immediately
is the D pawn so he'll take care of that
in a second all right black gets his
knight out of the way somehow he has to
get these pieces out so it isn't it
isn't clear how he's going to do it yet
now this Queen
defends the deep on but how queen to f2
so now if you play the movie for you got
your D pawn protected okay so alright is
this the moment so a nice move to Knight
f5 and now black had a tough problem he
doesn't really want to leave that night
there because it's a really strong night
so he ended up taking it which he also
doesn't really want to give him away his
Bishop but if you go back you just save
your rook White's going to play a move
like g4 and that Knights going to stay
there forever because if you ever take
it will take with a jeep on and we'll
get our rook on the G file that'd be
really dangerous so he ended up taking
it which so now II for is coming next
and there's not a lot you can do about
it he tries to you know get some
pressure he's hoping that once the the D
pawn moves out of the way and captures
you'll be able to put another rook on
the D file and you get a lot of pressure
on d4 but okay it's a you know
well-timed efore it's always a big
judgment of whether you want to do it or
not and black again has another hard
choice if you take which he did in the
game you're opening the F file and
that's what that's what ended up
happening if you don't then I'm playing
a5 and I'm going to follow it up with f4
and eventually you know these pawns are
going to start rolling down the board so
a tough choice he ended up taking it and
okay this is sort of blacks point he
gets a little bit of pressure going now
on the D pawn this is his only source of
counter play but when white has these
positions normally whenever he can play
the move e5 he's doing really good
because when the knight moves okay then
our Knight gets to jump into e4 and it's
you know going to be kind of a headache
for the second player here so when the
knight jumps in our Knight gets to go to
e4 okay now black it's it's not really
easy to suggest a lot that that you can
do if your black here so the knight gets
to go to d6 that's where he was headed
now here again the knight has pressure
on f7 we just need to move the bishop
out of the way
then okay black ears have to keep
defending f7 so he defends it again he
brings the Queen back and now you know a
nice move just a bishop efore with a lot
of threats he might bring the knight
back to f5 where to look at some you
know squares that might help animating
attack it's out of the F file so these
pieces are also attacking on f7 and if I
ever want to I can take the knight on d5
and I get rid of this this hole that I
have because you'll you'll take back and
then they'll be upon here and my D pawn
won't be as weak as it you know could be
okay so black tries to defend and now
another nice attacking move you can
attack the th pawn so he you know it's
makes him some serious threats here
forcing black to weaken his King side so
now it's white that's thinking about
checkmate here so he decides to
eliminate the knight and now his plan is
to get a rook up and over it might go
you know to f3 with more pressure here
it might go to h3 but he does something
really nice before he begins to move his
knight up the board he attacks the Queen
and forces her to a more passive
position if you just go for it right
away sometimes the Queen is going to be
able to come down and cause some some
problems and give it a little bit of
counter play on the Queen side so he
prevents all of that kicks the Queen
over to d6
not a very good square and now he can
begin maneuvering his rook
so the rook is probably going to have
three sometimes it might go to h3 we're
going to we're going to find out so
let's see all right so I spoiled a good
move but at Knight to f5 is a really
strong tactical move the point is if you
take where is the checkmate
RUP g3 okay so i'll block it keep going
Queen f6 excellent and now mate is
unstoppable so whatever you do I'm
taking on a g7 next and it's checkmate
okay
so there's there's no taking alright so
he moves his rook over now sometimes his
King if he needs to escape he can he has
the f8 square so after the chick he
moves over and we start to get all of
our pieces right by the King some point
this guy's coming over at the moment we
have the threat of checkmate
so black had to stop it the only way is
to use the knight to defend and so now
here it is White has all of his pieces
attacking f7 and it's more than black
can can possibly defend so his his game
is about to collapse here alright so he
continues to make a little bit more
escape squares and now's the time to
take on f7 and now we're threatening
lots of discoveries and it's just not
easy to play black so he takes the Queen
so the Queen will just move away there's
still so many threats all over the place
and okay so now he he blocks the F file
but not for very long the move the last
move of the game was played here just a
simple simple tactic here who can find
what white played g4 attacking a pinned
piece so the knight can't move because
then you know that the king of the king
is here so black it had enough he's
losing material his positions still
terrible and he's just going to get it
attacked and there's no hope so he gave
up okay so now we'll jump to another
game which is a specific variation this
is a more recent game entire anton core
above verse ernesto in ER kiev and it
was played earlier this year in the
world rapid tournament and i really like
the way white played on this game it
made it look so simple and easy and when
you play this variation as white this is
kind of what you're dreaming of he just
makes it look
a super-simple again we have an
invitation to a nympho Indian but we get
back and we have the exchange variation
all right with c6 and Queen c2 so
everything that all greven can dream up
this is his exact move order so we get
back to our starting position and he was
wondering if instead of castling what if
they put their night on h5 so this is
kind of a different variation they're
deviating from the main line and they're
forcing us to trade the dark squared
Bishop s' notice if we go back then
we're just handing over that the bishop
for no reason so we'll trade now it
seems like it's a little bit harder to
play f3 which is true so that's the the
big plus for black he's he's trying to
make that plan a little more difficult
and what's this Knight doing well he's
going to do the same sort of maneuver
he's going to put this knight on g7 this
time it's the other night that will come
to f6 and the bishop is coming to f5
protected by the pawn in the night and
trying to trade the like squared Bishop
for white that's so strong so it makes a
lot of sense for black to try to play
this way and okay y can also play with
Knight f3 and in this position
most people will Castle queenside which
is very common in these sorts of
structures but a quarter blob is one of
the highest rated playing guys that ever
play this opening and he mixes it up he
so he's a good guide if you want to
notice just this particular variation he
seems to get it a lot and usually he
castles on the Kings side and this keeps
kind of with the theme of today so we'll
have a look at this
probably we're going to end up playing
for a minority attack because it's going
to be hard to play f3 at least initially
so we'll see what happens
black castles rook b1 so we're going to
play b4 so blacks doing all of his
normal moves his next move is Knight f6
and then Bishop f5 so b4 now usually
black doesn't just let white play b5
he's going to play the move a6 to slow
you down a little bit and why it's
always going to respond with a 4 so this
is pretty typical
so now when ever b5 comes if it does
come you'll be able to play a takes and
then a takes and you'll get that
position where the rook is on the open a
file but in this game black took his
time to try to provoke white into
playing the move a5 and white obliged so
you can play the move b5 here but a5 is
quite a strong move and we'll try to
understand why black yeah you know force
the trade of dark-squared bishop s--
early and now we're looking at these
dark squares and they're pretty weak and
tender so he's dreaming of a day when
this knight can come to c5 and put a lot
of pressure on the beep on and that's
kind of what happens in the game so 9 a4
and now it's before he puts the knight
on c5 there's one more defender of the
dark squares that he should try to
eliminate so he played the move Queen c5
trying to trade Queens and then he'll be
able to put his knight on c5 so black
could follow my rule and always play
queen d8 that's a perfectly fine move
just avoiding the trade instead he
allowed the trade oh I didn't mind
and so at some point that Knight is
going to go to c5 ok but for the moment
he thinks well maybe I can revert back
to this plan because that's where all of
your pawn breaks are going to be in this
position so he gets his knight out of
the way the knight goes to g3 where it
supports the movie 4 he's going to bring
a rook in and he's going to try to play
for the movie 4 all right h5 so if if
white waits and this Knight gets kicked
around it flex allowed to play this he's
going to be in trouble because the
Knights going to have to like block you
know that the e pawn making f3
impossible or he's got to go to a silly
square so he puts this pawn on h4 and
it's this is a really nice positional
game here by white you'll notice almost
all of White's pawns are on dark squares
and he has a light squared bishop so his
bishop is really good you'll notice
black all of his pawns are on light
squares so this guy is going to have a
hard time finding a good job and so ok
so a nice move h4 which is actually
useful for the white player
okay so he's trying to you know maneuver
is Knight to d6 a very common strategy
that controls a lot of light squares you
can imagine the knight here and okay he
protects his pawn now he's ready to play
the move f3 so the knight comes to d6
and Danny's favorite move f3 yes yeah
okay so it's going to you know take some
time before you can play the movie for
but how does black get his pieces out he
decided to go here and now it's
interesting so white can decide if he
wants to trade the e pawn is attacked
again so he's probably going to trade
something and he decides to give up his
Bishop which is fine and now black takes
now he's ready to get his rook into the
game put some pressure here so let's see
now he he's a okay this guy he's just
hanging out now's the time for him to go
into c5 okay and now Danny's second
favorite move or is this your first
favorite move it's your first favorite
move okay so Danny knows but what did
white play here notice this is attacked
twice yeah
King f2 so Danny's impressed as promised
f3 king of - just protecting the pond
and okay he's going to what I like too
is now he just comes up with a very
simple way to improve this position
which is what you want to do here
there's not like you can do a ton but
what's a nice slow plan for white just
how does he improve his pieces like
particularly this guy you know he's not
necessarily the best here on f1 what's
that put it on the C file put a rook on
the C file yeah the problem is now this
guy is undefended again because I'm
attacking it twice so then that might
not work
right yeah rookie 2 was played so now
okay now you can put this rook somewhere
else probably on a 1 because he's trying
to play e4 right so it's just the slow
maneuver and often when you get this
position you're wondering like what
should I do
you should look for your worst piece and
try to make it a good piece usually
that's the answer
so rookie 2 makes a lot of sense okay
and what is black do I mean there's not
a whole lot he's going to do he's just
kind of holding he's being patient and
waiting and meanwhile white gets to
improve so now the quality of his rooks
is a little better and in just a second
he'll play e4 whenever he whenever he
feels like it
ok so he improves his King a little bit
now efore you'll notice when black takes
now when this guy is potentially weak
but blacks a long way from ever
attacking it so he takes back with a
knight and then C so what should what
should black do well he didn't want to
trade one of his knights and now wait
played a really nice move the best move
here and it's kind of funny
so the knight took on e4 we just want to
make sure we keep the e-file open and
now the knight jumps back to g3 ok so
the King comes over and now white is
winning so yeah so he didn't actually
have time to do this and I white it just
wins from this position who can see what
white did here it's tricky white now
kind of has the option of trading all of
the pieces and going into an endgame so
whatever you have this option like we
can take the knight and then take the
bishop and then trade all of the rooks
you want to make sure what's going to
happen in this endgame and you want to
make sure you calculate this because if
you're winning the King and pawn endgame
then you should just do this it's the
simplest way to win so he did indeed
take the knight going into this ending
black took back with a pawn if you take
with the bishop we can play a lot of
moves we can trade the rooks and then
take on b7 or we can just take b7 first
because if you take back you're losing
this rook
so you're at least going to lose upon
here but it's better than the
alternative which is letting white trade
all of the pieces so now again white can
just take everything if you don't take
back your down a piece so you end up in
this endgame and white is winning so
okay what's the most important in an
endgame like this is the activity of
your King white is a where's he going to
try to make a pass pawn because what
side of the board do you think he's
going to create a pastor here the Queen
side so he gets his king it's going to
come up to f4
maybe he'll munch on these pawns maybe
he'll just play the move g4 and he's
going to create a passer now it's it's
hard in this position to stop me from
playing g4 and making a passer if you
decide you want to go back it's funny
now what this white play to force sub
Swain g3 alright a lot of people got it
and now black is in Zug Swain he has to
move again I can't move any of his pawns
really and you know if the King moves
then that was just a slower way of what
happened in the game okay so the King
instead decides you know I got to eat up
these pawns but now it's over
because g4 forcing the trades here and
this guy is going to be too fast so you
can capture and now the pond anyway it's
clearly going to win this race this guy
has no chance because the King is right
here so he plays on for a few more moves
but okay after he has the Queen it's
just over so the game actually ended
right here okay so hopefully that was a
gives you a good idea of what to do when
you're playing in the Carlsbad pawn
structure and a little bit about how to
plan the pieces and how you should play
for both sides keep sending in your
submissions maybe I'll pick your your
favorite opening next week like face put
me on Facebook put me on the Internet do
all sorts of crazy stuff and I'll see
you guys next week